yes so in case you haven't heard Kylie
Jenner's new single rise and shine has
become an undeniable Bop but one person
who might not think so is her baby girl
stormy who was into the song right up
until this moment oh you want daddy
singing I'm not good enough okay okay
just to catch you up to speed at the
song in question went viral through one
of Kylie's YouTube videos where she
attempts to wake up baby stormy rise and
shine
the lyric has now spawned thousands of
memes and even caught the attention of
ariana grande who Kylie gave permission
to sample the song earlier this week
rise and shine
the beauty mogul even has her own rise
and shine merch
Kylie's Instagram post received a lot of
love from her other celebrity friends
including Travis Scott who wrote wild
earlier this month he learned that
reality star and Travis Scott were
taking a break shortly after the news
broke Kylie was spotted twice that week
at the same location as her ex boyfriend
Tyga but Kylie quickly denied those
claims on Twitter writing Travis and I
are in great terms in our main focus
right now is stormy our friendship and
our daughter is priority people say
things all the time some things I just
think feel like responding to so I just
felt like responding about a source
close to et tells us there is no bad
blood at all between them and it's
nothing but love and quote they're just
taking some time to figure things out
the source also adds that Kylie's
enjoying single life right now and she
and Travis are co-parenting amicably
rise and shine
[Music]